I want to start by saying again how much
I dig this movie this is just what we
call a really good film one of the
things that I think people are gonna be
surprised by is that it's really dirty
but it's also really sweet like it has
that it has a great mix like that can
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the script and the story that's you know
that's always been Edie's kind of thing
though right like like like mixing
genres you know like 48 hours he was
funny as hell but it was also action and
also he was a you know there's a serious
character and then Dolomites was that
you know he was he was badass he was
vulgar and but he also was like to care
his crew and you know he uh you know he
he show he was a leader you know he
persevered and in then one of the most
heart-wrenching moments is when a lady
devout lady I was go read lady read was
like you know I I never saw myself like
this like he literally picked her up and
believed in her and made her see
something in herself that she didn't
even know was there
you know completely you know dolomite is
definitely inspiration to the characters
you know not only the characters
inspiration to the audience that's
watching it and it's a life he's a life
teacher man he's teaching you about
dealing with self-esteem he's teaching
you about dealing with friends family
getting let down you know and he's still
persevered through it so you know I
think he's a definitely a tool God put
on this earth he probably didn't know he
was motivating the world when he was
doing it and he probably was just doing
it out of his own self thing but look
what ended up happening no completely
obviously I'm sure you both knew about
dolomite and Rudy prior to filming but
is there anything that you learned along
the way that surprised you or things you
didn't know
yeah I know huh I didn't know the full
story I just seen a couple of movies but
but um just his um has like just taken
no any meaning nothing to him like that
you can say no all you want but I'm
going to continue on like a tank you
know it was uh that just that's what I
really pulled away from the movie and
and figuring out who this man was
yeah that that uh movie theater that he
went to in Indianapolis was right down
the street from where I grew up at 42nd
Street 42nd and Carlton and uh college
and uh I didn't know that that was the
first movie theater that played his
movie in my hometown Wow that's a that's
a crazy connection it is yeah I'm trying
to process that like the full circle I'm
a big fan of Craig a different Craig
right exactly right uh it's a good name
talk a little bit about working with him
because he seems so like level-headed
and he just seems just seemed really
cool if you could share a little bit
about working with him
super laid back very collaborative very
trusting you know he he he let us play
with the material and um you know who
and he step in when he needed to pretty
much but he he he knows what's up you
know clearly you see the movie and I you
know and it was all good oh yeah Eddie
Murphy definitely a leader leader of the
pack knows how to leave the pack I
remember at one point we were sitting in
the head doing a scene I was like yeah
I'm glad I'm in this movie with you
because you could have played every part
in the movie I definitely have to ask
you about the music talked a little
about the songs and stuff and you got to
what you got to add I just got to sing
the songs and added my voice I don't
know what you mean but uh I just wanted
to you know represent Ben Taylor
correctly I mean he's much better
singing to me but it was uh I enjoy
seeing you seeing in movies well thank
you
I enjoy doing it it was a you know it
was a nice to see and I'm and it was
another song that get cut out the movie
we did a bar case too but you know it
just it makes me giddy to go in now it
was challenging because Craig Brewer
is a type who'd be like hey you heard a
song like no I haven't heard before
oh well you've seen the tomorrow camera
so get familiar yeah but uh other than
that it was it was was awesome I gotta
go
thank you both so much and seriously
congrats on the movie the real